he's calling the Lakers Clippers
showdown on Christmas Day at 8:00
Eastern on ABC and ESPN he joins us and
the Continental Tire Coaches Corner
he'll be alongside Mike Breen and Jeff
Van Gundy his finals broadcast teammates
they have called more NBA Finals events
than any other team we are wondering
good morning mark
we were wondering what poster you had on
your wall growing up so can we guess the
1 sports poster that you had Wow well
don't tell us yet but did you haven't
know I'm trying to think did I have one
if I had one go ahead and guess
oh you were gonna say - you're too poor
to get to it for two posters haven't you
ever he'll say we were fortunate just
that wall okay let me see if I went
around the room who would Mark Jackson
have on his wall I'll give you I'll give
you two guesses because two to two
people would have been on my wall as a
kid basketball family few nice but I
would okay one is basketball and one is
football I'm not gonna give you the
other guy I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
Muhammad Ali that is one absolutely go
wait how many points I'm looking for
Steve Harvey to put it up there on the
Family Feud there that's probably 80
points okay 80 points alright who wants
to who else wants to guess the poster
Mark Jackson had on his wall growing up
he barely had walls but the walls that
he did and two posters there I don't
think you'd get it okay only if you only
have you researched me okay well I feel
pretty good about this one
Bernard King princey I'm gonna go Bob
McAdoo
McLovin George Gervin George Gervin
that's a great guess and well no I got
Seaton's gotta get a chance here see say
Bill Russell but it's not Bill Russell I
don't know if they had posters of Bill
Russell back then okay I'm gonna get
let me see it wasn't Farrah Fawcett
right oh my goodness okay all right okay
the landers twins let me see who would
you have had a Walt Clyde Frazier that's
outstanding gasps OH
who wasn't you're getting you got warm
with Walt Clyde phrase you got very well
Earl Monroe there you go the winner is
Earl the Pearl Weldon okay number 15 the
whole early stages of my life thank you
Mark that's all we wanted to talk to you
about we appreciate your time
did you get a sense there was a passing
of the torch last night with the Lakers
and bucks with the Greek freak there I
don't think I don't think that's fair I
think it's fair to say that there's a
another guy up there in the discussion
with you know several guys the way he's
played not just this year but the guy
had an incredible year last year and he
was the MVP for a reason so I think we
forget I forgot how great he's been
lately so he's in the discussion for the
best player in the world and he's been
that way for over a year now and I think
it was it was awesome to see him on a
big stage against greatness accepted
challenge and you know LeBron had a
great game also you know the Bucs are
just a heck of a basketball team and and
Yanis is a tremendous tremendous
all-time great player all right is he
the best player in the game I don't
think it's for me it's not fair to say
that right now because you know LeBron
James are still in the game and he's
still 17 years later playing at an
incredible clip so I'm gonna give it to
LeBron I'm gonna say Yanis is right
there Kevin Durant even though he's out
is right there Kawhi Leonard is right
there Wade Lucas plan obviously James
hard I mean this this league is in some
tremendous hands who's in a better shape
right now the Lakers of the Clippers
since you had that game on Christmas
night
both teams have a legitimate chance to
win it all I think that the Clippers
have probably better depth and more you
know they got three guys they can give
the ball to in Kauai and Paul and in Lou
Williams that can make a play when it
matters most I think like we saw last
night that can be a tough times for the
Lakers you know when you pay attention
to LeBron and Anthony Davis and dance
somebody else that make a play now they
can do it but will they do it
consistently consistently I've seen
those other three guys do it on the big
big stage with the bright lights and
they won't be effective what is the one
thing that worries you about the Lakers
well just what I said that's the biggest
thing yeah I think they need somebody
else that can create offense to take the
pressure off of LeBron and Anthony Davis
and not just offense that they create
for them but that special player a
special talent or the guy that has the
ability can get his own and make plays I
mean that's not Kuzma Kuzma is a scorer
he's a he's a scorer that you know it's
a different way than the guys that I
mentioned for example Kawhi or Paul or
Lou you give them the basketball they
make plays I don't think Kuzma is that
guy he's the guy that can score in
bunches running slashing aggressively
shooting he's a heck of a player but he
scores differently talking to Mark
Jackson ESPN and ABC NBA analyst as he
will have the call coming up Christmas
night that'll be between the Lakers and
the Clippers what is Kevin Garnett
talking about that
the Celtics broke LeBron James and
that's why he went to Miami because of
the Celtics do you follow this what kg
had to say to Bill Simmons on his
podcast I saw that headlines and I
understand the headlines but you know
they want a championship and they they
beat the Bron James take credit I don't
you know I watched those games I covered
a lot of those games I didn't see a
broken guy so a guy that was defeated
and lost and took to a better team at
the time well you have the Celtics who
have kg hall-of-famer Paul Pierce
hall-of-famer Ray Allen
hall of famer rajon rondo maybe a
borderline hall of famer and he says
yeah lebron couldn't beat us five and I
thought does he even stop and listen to
what he just said it was LeBron couldn't
beat r5 and that's why he went to Miami
yeah he couldn't get anybody who wanted
to go to Cleveland and you know kg
didn't do anything when he was in
Minnesota when he had a roster similar
to what LeBron had in Cleveland so I
like that that Celtic team talks more
trash than any other team and they only
won one title you're gonna say that
LeBron was broken then therefore LeBron
broke those guys when he left I don't
think it's fair I think that shelters
were the better basketball team and have
you gonna say that I would disagree with
the notion that Michael Jordan broke
Reggie and I who he came closer to no no
no no no they were just a better
basketball team and he was a longtime
great player so give him credit and move
on I don't I don't think it makes sense
to go back and you know take shots and
in that type of way Kevin Garnett is
about to be a Hall of Famer yeah well
deserved
tremendous player but at the end of the
day the Celtics won with an outstanding
unit and I'll standing coach you got a
Jordan story that I haven't heard not
that not one that I want to share with
you I think you know I'll keep it on
tucked-away I'm a guy that saw well I'm
not gonna tell those stories those are
great stories you know I tell you what
an all-time great player obviously and
an all-time great competitor across the
board yeah I know I know you gonna say I
know I know but I asked you yeah I did I
asked you a question you got a got a
great I had Rick Carlisle on yesterday
he's telling all these Larry Bird
stories yes yes Rick played with Larry
and they were you know I went to I went
to Larry's house with Rick so that
that's okay you want a Reggie Miller
story I give you one of them but what's
Larry Bird's house like well the funny
thing is you know Rick Rick tells Reggie
and I when we plan for the Pacers you
know Larry wants to meet with you guys
are we like okay well let's go to his
office where he's I know he wants me to
take you to his house so we could drive
about 30 minutes away and we get to the
house and Rick doesn't even knock on the
door
Rick opens the door I'm like that's my
guy he's my brother I'm not opening up
his door I'm wait all of a sudden Rick
call out is guiding Richie and I into
the house and he's on birdie birdie
birdie we're looking for bird and our
head coach and all-time great is
absolutely knocked out ten minutes later
we find him on the couch with the covers
over his head wait he knows you're
coming over and he's asleep
birdie all comes out from underneath the
covers
I saw where a Tracy Morgan endorsed you
as the next Knicks head coach that was
nice I didn't see that long I'm not
gonna lie I saw it but they have a head
coach in the you know he's done a
outstanding job since taking over and I
wish them nothing but the best I look
forward to one day being a coach again
in this league and I appreciate the love
and support by Tracy Morgan putting a
stamp on me as a coach in theory would
you want to coach the Knicks over
anybody else in theory I want to coach I
there's dirty precious jobs in this
league and it's a tremendous honor and
privilege to take the helm and lead an
organization I look forward to doing
that one day you know it's a friend I
would advise you to not take that job
well if offered didn't I say 30 jobs I
know I'm just wrong about the Knicks any
job I'm just on the no thanks no I'm not
gonna there's 30 jobs you would advise
me not to take a child no no the next
job okay well I would say this I do have
an incredible job and if I died a
hundred years from now calling all these
finals and and it working for you know
ABC ESPN and Disney I'd be a happy man
so I'm excited about the privilege to
call games I don't take that for granted
and I'm calling games with people that I
absolutely love so I'm having the time
of my life doing it and I'm not I'm not
a guy that stressed out thinking about
anything else what about Van Gundy is he
dying to get by
coach well I can't speak for him I'm
sure he looks forward to coaching I will
tell you this the guy is an incredible
basketball mind and having the privilege
to have played for several times I will
tell you he is as good as it gets as a
coach nobody wild work them no one would
be more prepared and I'm proud as his
partner the job that he did putting USA
basketball in position to win a goal and
then listening to the players on that
team man from an express how how awesome
he was in the scouting reports his
preparation and his job as coach of USA
I mean he was I mean it's it's a
no-brainer to me if I was if I was
running a team I would hide a man today
when I without a doubt would you hire
him over you yeah because I'm hiring oh
you're the hiring okay
okay that means that means we both go
okay are you are you second on the
all-time assist list are you third no no
no I'm actually for Steve Nash has me by
one assist his clothes back on are you
kidding me Steve but when I look at the
list and I see LeBron last night passing
the great Gary Gary Payton for ninth
all-time and I'm looking at the 10 guys
in the top 10 and I really I'm really
just you know tier comes on my eyes when
I see my name on a list because those
are guys being a guy that followed the
game those are those are the best at
several place and I'm truly humbled to
be on the list and their tears that come
out of other guy's eyes by saying Mark
Jackson had that many assist our young
anyway the way you felt about me when we
first met you like are you kidding me
sir I didn't say you showed you so much
respect and appreciation that I was
trash but you was you were not moved by
Martin my my abilities oh not on the
floor but I was as a broadcaster who
comes up to you and say I can outshoot
you I mean it is you I got it all these
years later you out alive I was out of I
was out of line that day but I got into
your kitchen a little bit no no I'm glad
that I put you back in line by taking
you I would love to
love to shoot against you again no this
is boxing you're in the past I'm not
giving you a rematch like give me an
opportunity here kitty kitty kitty kitty
kitty kitty all I know is that even I
may even come to your home court to get
it done I tell them right this is Mark
Jackson you call this is not Reggie
Miller you call Wow Wow no I wouldn't
challenge Reggie I would never challenge
Reggie to three-point shooting contest
no no not reg and you know what I'm
doing with you this time you can't go
top of the key I'm taking you into the
corner you don't you're the Challenger
you know you know Express the rules okay
we're going to the corner
all right when you when you take over
the Knicks I'll come down there and hey
great to talk to you have fun on
Christmas night best of the family and
always great talking to you likewise man
happy holidays love you bro thank you
that's mark Jackson for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]